[Musique]
avec mon pour en parler rudyard des six
avocats spécialisés dans le droit pénal
médical vous défendent également en ce
moment entre autres à une employée
d'hôpital qui refusent de se faire
vacciner bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
à vos côtés bruno mais garman un chef du
service d'animation l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris bon soir docteur
merci également à vous d'être là
beaucoup de réaction ce soir c'est un
sujet qui évidemment fait toujours
parler qui est qui vend 1 on sent déjà
rendu compte sur ce plateau n'est ce pas
docteur mais gare banon va dire tout de
suite commencer par ce commentaire un
des railleries de noter des spectateurs
ce soir
cette réaction de stéphanie notre chef
gouvernement va peut-être proposer une
carte de fidélité à la 8ème dose et bien
il ya des bons pour aller au restaurant
message est également de david healy a
déjà deux doses de trop entre
l'obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions et la vaccination forcée via
le pas de sanitaires ce gouvernement en
a déjà trop fait petite colère chez les
téléspectateurs
qui ont réagi revient v6 en prolongeant
le pass and i ter jusqu'à l'été est ce
que justement le gouvernement va trop
loin
mon sens il faut un moment de lire
arrêtez toutes les mesures que l'on
prend chez le sentiment mais c'est un
sentiment personnel au début de la crise
en mars 2020 on n'avait pas suffisamment
appréhender l'ampleur du désastre qui
allait tomber sur la france et puis
aujourd'hui pour essayer de récupérer un
petit peu une situation qui a été
réellement dramatique parce qu'il faut
comprendre que les gens ne veulent plus
de cette situation de confinement de
d'enfermement de cessation d'activité
est bon train des mesures peut-être
aujourd'hui disproportionnée par rapport
à la réalité la réalité clinique sur le
terrain
mais c'est un petit peu voilà qui a été
coupée j'en profite pour faire rebondir
renault mégane et des mesures docteur
disproportionnée pour vous est également
qu'ils ne sont plus justifiés si on suit
l'idée de rudyard v6
alors j'ai été abandonné par mais mes
deux invités bruno meyer ban voilà je
suis contente de voir qu'on vous a
récupéré
des mesures peut-être disproportionnée
c'est ce que nous explique l instant
rudy rb6 mais c'est aussi le sentiment
qu'ont beaucoup de français aujourd'hui
on tire trop sur la corde ou s'est
justifié selon vous
alors je suis désolé effectivement la
production le pas très bonne donc je
n'entends pas très bien les questions
malgré tout il faut savoir que le schéma
de vaccination
ne relève pas d'une décision politique
ou d'un choix d'un gouvernement d'un
ministre de la santé ce sont les études
scientifiques
ce sont les données médicales qui décide
si un vaccin d'hôtes est administré en
deux trois ou quatre doses et s'il faut
faire des rappels et à quel rythme alors
c'est vrai qu'avec la qu'ovide nous
découvrons le schéma vaccinal au en même
temps que nous vaccinons les individus
et que nous voyons évidemment
la réponse que nous analysons la réponse
immunitaire à cette vaccination c'est là
où il y a on va dire une certaine
incompréhension de la population
mais il faut le dire ça n'est pas une
décision politique le choix de faire une
troisième dose ou un rappel relève des
données observationnelles qui montre que
les anticorps neutralisants acquis à la
suite de la vaccination se réduisent
avec le temps se réduisent de façon
significative au delà du 6e mois et
pourrait ne pas être suffisant pour
protéger les personnes les plus âgées et
les personnes n'arrivent regarde les
filles d'accord avec cette analyse
ce n'est pas une décision politique de
décidé d'administrer une une vaccination
mais c'est peut-être une décision
politique de la conditionner opa
sanitaire
vie au téléphone
on vous entend on à votre image et c'est
bien on à votre sont alors on va faire
avec effectivement c'est bien mais je
vais vous donner quelques indications
comptes ont été eu la semaine dernière
on a participé ensemble à lyon la
semaine dernière
les chiffres rouges a indiqué qu'il y
soit encore par
julie d'érable une semaine après on
arrive actuellement à 15 morts par jour
quand le conseil d'état a statué sur le
passé ni terre en mai de 21 ils vivent à
lui est le nom pour deux personnes qui
étaient conçus
voilà alors on a de nouveau perdu
décidément regard baissé ça va être
compliqué mais nous excuser en tout cas
pour ces problèmes de connexion ce soir
on va essayer d'aller un petit peu plus
loin et
si besoin en malheureusement
n'interrompra ce débat bruno merga
bornes la vente vous faire réagir à
nouveau je voudrai justement vous faire
écouter jean castex dans le prolongement
de ce que vous nous disiez ce sont les
autorités médicales qui choisissent
écouter jean castex était lundi dernier
depuis le vatican
les conditions pour bénéficier du pass
sont fixés par la haute autorité de
santé à la haute autorité de santé de
nous dire si nous devons ou non étendre
l'éligibilité du pass à la troisième
dose la vie est sollicité hong renault
mégane évidemment c'est ça qui me le feu
aux poudres parce qu'elle est les anti
vhc le début voilà qu'on aura peut-être
du mal à convaincre de votre point de
vue mais il ya aussi ceux qui ont
peut-être joué le jeu qui ont fait leurs
deux doses wall a sagement pour eux mais
aussi pour une immunité collective cette
idée d'une troisième dose est ce que ce
n'est pas jean revient jane d'un très
bon débat la danse doteront
non je ne crois pas vous voyez un
certain nombre de vaccins pour obtenir
et avoir la garantie d'une protection
nécessite plusieurs doses et d injection
de rappel le vaccin contre le tétanos et
bien on en reçoit trois doses au moment
de la naissance puis une première dose
de rappel à un an puis tous les cinq ans
puis tous les dix ans donc vous voyez
que le schéma de vaccination dépend du
mode d'action du vaccin et lorsque le
vaccin est dit inerte c'est à dire ne
contient pas un virus inactivé c'est le
cas par exemple des vaccins contre lacko
vide eh bien il faut faire des rappels
relativement répéter voyez quand on
prend un antibiotique pour traiter une
infection bactérienne et bien on ne
conteste pas la durée de
l'antibiothérapie celle-ci peut-être en
une seule dose pour tel type de microbes
et elle peut être ce tueur plusieurs
jours parfois plusieurs mois pour tel
autre type de bactéries donc ce sont les
données scientifiques vous on entendu
j'ai entendu votre idée mais on a le
sentiment
que ça ne va pas s'arrêter ne pas avoir
de visibilité sur les vaccins que vous
mon site et voilà on a une connaissance
aussi qu'ils auront c'est qu'il ya un
calendrier vaccinal qui est préétabli là
on se dit ça ne va jamais s'arrêter
alors vous avez raison donc en tout cas
pour le moment il est recommandé de
faire une troisième doses pour une
population à très haut risque
lorsque l'immunité des croix c'est le
cas des personnes de plus de 65 ans des
personnes avec comorbidités nous
espérons tous évidemment que peut-être
cette dose de rappel sera suffisante
pour renforcer de façon massive
l'immunité et éviter de nouvelles doses
maintenant nous ne sommes pas à l'abri
de l'apparition de nouveaux variants et
que l'immunité au final ne soit pas
suffisante et qu'il faille à nouveau
recourir à des rappels il faut savoir
qu'en parallèle la recherche progresse
et que on essaie de mettre au point des
vaccins plus efficaces avec une durée de
réponse plus importante et qu'ils
puissent évidemment donner une était
face à tout type de variants y compris
les variants qui ne sont toujours pas
apparu redire mais si l'on vous a
récupéré je vais vous laisser réagir sur
ce qui s'est dit en espérant vous ayez
pu suivre un petit peu les les
développements c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de levée de boucliers
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle beaucoup
crient à une atteinte aux libertés
publiques on enjambe la présidentielle
donc la question est est ce que pour
vous tout cela et et politique le
docteur nous disait d'instants n'ont
cessé médical et celle dictée par une
situation qu'il impose sanitaire donc il
ya des chiffres qui parlent
[Musique]
d'eux d'avoir une double immunité
l'immunité vaccinale et tout le monde en
est d'accord et il n'immunise est aussi
personnel biologique et ça il faut faire
comme quand même confiance au corps
humain maintenant qu' il y ait une
troisième dose qu'ils soient
éventuellement proposer à des personnes
qui ont des comorbidités qui sont des
personnes âgées qui sont des personnes
fragiles je crois que là tu le débat n'a
pas lieu tout le monde est pratiquement
d'accord là où on trouve qu'il y a des
limites qui ont été dépassés c'est quand
on impose le vaccin à certaines
personnes et pas à d'autres quand on
importe du vaccin à des enfants âgés de
moins de 12 ans et quand on impose à
toute la population dépasse sanitaires
voyez l'exemple des pays nordiques que
ce soit la hollande le danemark la suède
le une ouverture a été créée je pense
que quelque part il faut redonner cette
liberté aux citoyens bien entendu sous
le contrôle des chiffres qui nous seront
transmises semaine impressionné bien
entendu ils ne font pas
bon gars mais c'est ce qui m'avait a
décidément quittait définitivement merci
en tout cas bruno mais regardons en
avant n'a compris en tout cas le vos
messages respectifs merci d'avoir été
avec nous et veuillez nous excuser
encore pour cette connexion approximatif
ce soir merci à vous